- [Instructor] In a previous video,
we introduced ourselves
to the idea of bonds
and the idea of ionic bonds,
where one atom essentially is able
to take electrons from another atom.
But then because one
becomes positively charged
and the other becomes negatively charged,
they get attracted to each other.
Now we're going to go to the other end
of the bonding spectrum,
where instead of stealing
electrons from each other,
we're going to share them.
Let's say we're dealing
with two oxygen atoms.
So let me draw one oxygen here.
A neutral oxygen has
eight electrons total,
but six of them are in its outer shell.
So it has one,
two, three,
four, five,
six valence electrons.
And the way that I arrange
them is I pair them up last.
So you have these two valence electrons
that are not paired with another electron.
And now let me draw another oxygen,
and I'm going do it
with a different color,
so we can keep track of the electrons.
So another oxygen right over there,
also has six valence
electrons, one, two, three,
four, five, six valence electrons.
Now this oxygen on the left,
in order to become more stable,
it would love to somehow gain
or maybe share two more electrons.
And of course, this oxygen on
the right, it's still oxygen.
It also would love to gain
or share two more valence electrons.
So how could it do it?
Well, what if the oxygen on
the left shared this electron
and this electron with
the oxygen on the right,
and the oxygen on the
right shared this electron
and this electron with
the oxygen on the left?
Well, if they did that,
you would have something
that looks like this.
You have your oxygen on the left.
You have the oxygen on the right.
And the way we show two
electrons that are being shared,
let's say these two
electrons are being shared,
is just a line like this.
This shows that there are two electrons
that are being shared
by these two oxygens.
And let's say that these two electrons
are also being shared.
You would do that with a line like this.
And then we could draw the remainder
of the valence electrons.
This oxygen on the left had,
outside of the electrons
that are being shared,
it had four more valence electrons.
And then the oxygen on the right
had four more valence electrons,
one, two, three, four.
Now what's interesting here
is the shared electrons,
these are going to cause these
oxygens to stick together.
If they don't stick together,
these electrons aren't going to be shared.
So what we have formed here
is known as a covalent bond,
covalent bond.
And what's interesting is it
allows both of these oxygens
in some ways to be more stable.
From the left oxygen's point of view,
it had six valence electrons,
but now it's able to share two more.
Remember, each of these bonds,
each of these lines
represent two electrons.
So this oxygen could say, hey,
I get to have one, two, three, four,
six, eight electrons
that I'm dealing with,
and the same thing is going to be true
of this oxygen on the right.
Now there are some covalent bonds
that are between not-so-equals.
So for example, if we're
talking about water
and if we're talking about how
oxygen bonds with hydrogen.
So if we have oxygen right over here,
once again, I can draw its six
valence electrons, one, two,
three, four, five,
and let me just draw the
sixth one right over there.
And if I have hydrogen,
hydrogen has one valence electron.
So let's say that's a
hydrogen right over there
with one valence electron,
maybe another hydrogen right over there
with one valence electron.
Oxygen and hydrogen form covalent bonds.
In fact, that is how water is formed.
And so what would that look like?
Well, it would look like this.
You have oxygen right over here.
You have these two pairs of
electrons that I keep drawing.
And then this electron right over here
could be shared with the hydrogen,
and that hydrogen's
electron could be shared
with the oxygen.
So that forms a covalent
bond with this hydrogen.
And then this electron
from the oxygen can be
shared with the hydrogen,
and that electron from
the hydrogen can be shared
with the oxygen.
And so that would form a covalent bond
with that other hydrogen.
And now here, once again,
oxygen can kinda pretend
like it has eight valence electrons,
two, four, six, eight.
And the hydrogens can kind of pretend
that it has two valence electrons.
But the one difference here is that oxygen
is a lot more electronegative
than hydrogen.
It's to the right of hydrogen.
It's in this top-right corner, outside of,
other than the noble gases,
that really like to hog electrons.
So what do you think is
going to happen here?
Well, the electrons in each
of these covalent bonds
are going to hang out around the oxygen
more often than around the hydrogen.
So if the electrons spend
more time around the oxygen,
you're going to have, in general,
more negative charge around the oxygen.
And so you're going to have
a partial negative charge
on the oxygen end of the water molecule,
and then you're going to
have partial positive charges
on the hydrogen ends of the molecules.
And in case you're curious,
that little symbol I'm using for partial,
that's the lowercase Greek letter delta,
which is just the convention in chemistry.
And so this type of covalent bond,
because there is some polarity,
one side has more charge than the other,
this is known as a polar covalent bond,
polar covalent bond.